[Music]
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a free a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these memories something
in my past is the key to all of this
you're not a bladders thing we'll see
that's a yes or no question
yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
I think I had a life here
what are you telling me
we've come a long way but you're not as
strong as you think
[Music]
the slaw is just the beginning
I'm not going to fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sure the cutest little thing
what's your name we need heroes we need
you Captain Marvel is about somebody who
goes on a journey of discovery and I
think it was really important for
bringing to learn how to fight by the
time we started shooting I've been
training for nine months and I'm glad
that I did
doing my sequences up and down I trained
for three days
well kind of alive the thing that I
found so unique about this character was
that sense of humor mixed with total
capability and whatever challenge comes
her way you know how to fly this thing
you see which I realized after going to
the Air Force Base is really what Air
Force pilots are like that's a yes or no
question yes
we simulated a dogfight we were on
offense we were on the defense we got to
6.5 G's amazing it's a lot a lot of work
she brings so much of that to the role
it's pretty awesome strolls are the bad
guys
and you're a Kree a race of noble
warriors noble warrior heroes we found
you
we made you one of us
this war it's just the beginning
I'm not gonna fight your war
I'm gonna end it
lunch is a good look see did you have a
rough day agent fury I'm gonna need
clarification on this space invasion
Scrolls are infiltrating your planet
they're shapeshifters
[Music]
okay prove the announced grow
[Music]
that's a photon blast and I was groping
I'll do that I'm just supposed to take
your word today
we are Cree strong United
control
I have this power
but I don't know where it came from I've
never seen anything like her you think
you can find us she's just the beginning
[Music]
you come a long way making us strong as
you think
what is this seal logo announcing your
identity on clothing help with the
covert part of your job said the space
soldier was wearing a rubber suit get
tickets now your life began the day it
nearly ended we saved you you were
reborn
something in my past is the key to all
of this
the floor is just the beginning I'm not
gonna fight your war I'm gonna end it
[Music]
war is a universal language
I know renegade so - mercy never
occurred to me that one might come from
above
space invasion
big car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
to let miss you today so you're not from
around here it's hard to explain
I keep having these memories
I see flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
[Music]
but I can't tell if it's real
[Music]
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we need you
I'm not what you think I am
[Music]